swimming to extinction that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
i think
the guidelines they step forward are
very good and
do
a very good job of
promoting inclusivity while keeping
um
competitional integrity um
going
whatever
competitional integrity transgender
u-pen swimmer leah thomas professed to
believe in was shattered last night at
the ivy league championship
thomas heads in for the final turn
it's going gonna be a race for second
place it might be
penn going one two with beroker making
the turn currently in second place
and over the last half of the pool
nobody will touch leah thomas
who will finish at 4 30 7 32. leah
thomas ivy league champion in the 500
free
now thomas not only won that 500-yard
freestyle race by a stunning margin it
was about a half a length of the pull
thomas also established a new record for
harvard university's pool
now even the announcers kind of tacitly
admitted that it wasn't thomas's intense
training or dedication to the craft that
was necessarily responsible for the
victory
but something else
you can see the strokes the powerful
stroke of
leah thomas where
there isn't a whole lot of movement in
her leg she's using a lot of upper body
to reach and and pull and it's a much
quieter stroke even as it's more
powerful than a lot of these other
swimmers right now
well i mean you know you can't say what
he's probably thinking but anyone who
knows even the basics of competitive
swimming realizes that deriving power
from only the arms
isn't natural
now this is 2022. so of course thomas
wasn't the only first who made it to the
top of the podium yale's isaac hennig a
transgender man who has not even yet
begun hormone therapy so remains
eligible to swim on the women's team
set a new pool record in the 50-yard
freestyle
so what's wrong here
are we a civilization as americans
really okay with what we're witnessing
is everyone afraid to speak out
listen to the heartbreak in the words of
thomas teammates one anonymous pen
swimmer back in december described her
teammates to out-kick as upset and
crying
feeling quote so discouraged because no
matter how much work they put in
they're going to lose
a month later another told fox news that
the ncaa they doesn't actually care
about women at all
well i hate to say this but she's right
last month the ncaa took the cowards
route saying it would defer to the rules
of each sport and their governing body
to determine the eligibility of trans
athletes
now when usa swimming released an update
to its policies a couple of weeks back
requiring these transgender women to
have half the previous level of
testosterone thomas was allowed to
compete under originally well the ncaa
stepped in citing potentially
detrimental impacts to schools
and student athletes
what
and last week the ncaa said it wouldn't
alter the previously approved higher
testosterone threshold for transgender
women to compete
clearing the way for thomas to be in the
pool this week
and next month
now these fellow swimmers know this
entire exercise is a charade
so why won't they stand up and refuse to
participate
well i'll tell you why they're
intimidated because the entirety of
society is weighing against them
the coaches are cowards
and one swimmer from penn said pretty
much everyone individually has spoken to
our coaches about not liking this our
coach mike schnur
just really likes winning though
the media then of course cheerleads the
perversion of sex roles as in garashi an
actual reporter for the new york times
wrote
leah thomas is just the latest elite
athlete in the last century who has been
subject to anatomical chromosomal or
hormonal scrutiny
to compete in women's events
one thing they all have in common
they were winning
of course they pushed the propaganda
so what is your message then to these
state officials to to these parents who
are concerned that cisgendered athletes
will be edged up by trans athletes
yeah there is there's no uh there's no
reason to believe that there's been no
proof trans people have not ever
dominated in sports we are participating
with our peers
love the stash um i'll tell that to the
girls in the pool last night
and finally the most powerful liberals
in america they encourage it
there's administration have guidance for
schools on dealing with disputes rising
over trans girls competing
against and with cis girls i would just
say that the president's belief is that
trans rights are human rights and that's
why he signed that executive order
believe schools should offer the
opportunity for students to engage in
extracurricular activities
even if they're transgender i think
that's their right
but what about the rights of the girls
the young women who've trained for years
sometimes decades
in pursuit of their greatness pursuit of
pool records
well too bad according to the white
house and pretty much all the culture
just like everything else in the past
two years
it's left to gop governors to stand for
principles now several states have
already passed laws protecting girls
sports by keeping transgender girls
college-age women from playing in school
sports leagues matching their gender
identity they include florida texas
mississippi and south dakota among
others now that's interesting where have
we seen those states leading the way
before
remember covet
but it takes more than just state action
that can always be challenged in court
you can find a judge to overturn pretty
much anything these days and as we've
seen from virginia though to california
and everywhere in between
when concerned citizens
get together unafraid and push back with
logic and common sense basic biology
parents and neighbors say this just
isn't what we want for our future our
kids futures
you know you can all make a difference
the issue of what's going on in the
pools
track and field
girls sports women's sports college
athletics
deserves the same passion
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else